all of ours
okay
okay
oh
yes
yes
happy
um
you're good
[Music]
okay
yes
yes
yep
i appreciate it
wow
amen
so
yes
uh
did you set the camera named
oh
yes
is
is
make sure
i know that's what i noticed
what's wrong
um
this is
is
yes
directory
um
i do not have
are you hearing me
is
[ __ ]
here
oh
yes
my mind
so
so
right
okay
i know
all right
there you go
anyways
thank you
okay
thank you very much my fellow americans
apart from matters of
war and peace the nomination of a
supreme court justice
is the most important decision an
american
president can make for this reason
candidates for
president owe the american people
a specific list of individuals they
consider
for the united states supreme court four
years ago i announced my first list
of highly qualified candidates and
promised to
fill justice scalia's vacant seat
from from among those names and just
days after
my inauguration i kept that promise when
i nominated
judge neil gorsuch and
as you know he has been very spectacular
a year later i nominated and the senate
confirmed another
outstanding justice brett kavanaugh by
the end of my first term we will have
confirmed a record number of federal
judges over 300
all of whom will faithfully uphold our
constitution as written
what has always made america exceptional
is our reverence for the impartial rule
of law
people have come from all over the world
to pursue the american dream based on
this
sacred principle equality under the law
is the bedrock of our society it is the
principle that inspired american heroes
to abolish slavery and end segregation
secure civil rights and build the most
free and just nation in history
unfortunately there is a growing radical
left
movement that rejects the principle of
equal treatment under the law
if this extreme movement is granted a
majority on
the supreme court it will fundamentally
transform america without a single vote
of congress radical justices
will erase the second amendment silence
political speech and require
taxpayers to fund extreme late term
abortion
they will give unelected bureaucrats the
power to destroy
millions of american jobs they will
remove the words
under god from the pledge of allegiance
they will unilaterally declare the death
penalty unconstitutional
even for the most depraved mass
murderers
they will erase national borders [ __ ]
police departments
and grant new protections to anarchists
rioters violent criminals and terrorists
in the recent past many of our most
treasured freedoms
including religious liberty free speech
and the right to keep and bear arms
have been saved by a single vote on the
united states supreme court
our cherished rights are at risk
including the
right to life and our great second
amendment
over the next four years america's
president will choose hundreds of
federal judges and
in all likelihood one two three and even
four supreme court justices
the outcome of these decisions will
determine whether we hold fast to our
nation's founding principles or whether
they are lost forever that is why today
i am announcing 20 additions to my
original list
of candidates for the united states
supreme court
should there be another vacancy on the
supreme court during my presidency
my nominee will come from the names i
have shared with the american public
including the original list and these
20 editions joe biden has refused to
release his list
perhaps because he knows the names are
so extremely far left that they could
never withstand public scrutiny
or receive acceptance he must release a
list of justices
for people to properly make a decision
as to how they will vote
it is very important that he do so
my original list of potential justices
include many of our nation's brightest
legal minds such as bill pryor
amy coney barrett and thomas hardiman
outstanding people like those
distinguished individuals the
20 editions i am announcing today would
be
jurists in the mold justices antonin
scalia
clarence thomas and samuel alito
their names are as follows
bridget baidee of arizona
judge on the ninth circuit court of
appeals
daniel cameron of kentucky
attorney general of the commonwealth of
kentucky
paul clement of virginia
former solicitor general of the united
states
senator tom cotton of arkansas
senator ted cruz of texas
stewart kyle duncan of louisiana
judge on the fifth circuit court of
appeals
stephen engel of the district of
columbia
assistant attorney general for the
office of legal counsel
at the department of justice noel
francisco former solicitor general of
the united states
senator josh hawley of missouri
james hoe of texas judge on the fifth
circuit court of appeals
gregory katsis of virginia judge on the
district of columbia circuit court of
appeals
barbara lugoa of florida
judge on the 11th circuit court of
appeals
christopher landau of maryland united
states ambassador to mexico
carlos mooneys of florida justice on the
supreme court of florida
martha packhald of illinois
judge on the district court for the
northern district of
illinois peter phipps of pennsylvania
judge on the third circuit court of
appeals
sarah pitlik of missouri
judge on the district court for the
eastern district of missouri
allison jones rushing of north carolina
judge on the fourth circuit court of
appeals
kate todd of virginia deputy assistant
to the president and deputy council to
the president
lawrence van dyke of nevada judge on
the ninth circuit court of appeals
every one of these individuals will
ensure equal justice
equal treatment and equal rights for
citizens of every race
color religion and crete together we
will defend our
righteous heritage and preserve our
magnificent american
way of life thank you god bless america
thank you very much does anybody have
any questions on the
judges please anybody one of the judges
excuse me
any questions they're outstanding people
very important decision very important
that
joe biden put up potential nominees i
think it's a very important thing for
our country that he do that okay please
go ahead do you have a question
any questions we're spoken to these
attention can you address the
uh concerns from the woodwork book in
regards to
whether did you mislead the public by
saying
that you downplayed uh the coronavirus
and that you repeatedly
did that in order to reduce did you
well i think if you said in order to
reduce panic perhaps that so the fact is
i'm
a cheerleader for this country i love
our country and i don't want people
to be frightened i don't want to create
panic as you say
and certainly i'm not going to drive
this country or the world into a frenzy
we want to show confidence we want to
show strength we want to show strength
as a nation
and that's what i've done and we've done
very well we've done
well from any standard you look at our
numbers compared to other countries
other parts of the world
it's been an amazing job that we've done
i think it's very sad in many respects
because
the incredible individuals working so
hard on it including our vice president
they've done this great job they haven't
been acknowledged by the
news media and they should for the job
we've done whether it's ventilators and
now you'll see
very soon with vaccines and with
therapeutics
the job we've done has been incredible
but we don't want to
we don't want to instill panic we don't
want to jump up and down and start
shouting that we have a problem that is
a tremendous problem scare everybody and
i'll tell you the other thing we
immediately started buying all over the
world we started buying
masks and gowns and everything else and
we don't want to cause
uh pricing to go up to a level that
becomes
almost unaffordable so yeah and that
said so in that sense i agree with it
yeah please
how do you reassure the american public
going forward that they can trust what
you're saying
well i think that's really a big part of
trust we have to have leadership we have
to show leadership and the last thing
you want to do is
create a panic in the country this was a
horrible thing it was sent to us by
china
should not have happened should never
have happened this is a disgusting
terrible situation uh that was fostered
upon us
and uh we have to show we just don't
want to use the best word is panic we
don't want to have to show panic we're
not going to show panic
and that's exactly what i did and i was
very open whether it's to woodward or
anybody else it's just another
political hit job but whether it was
woodward or anybody else
you cannot show a sense of panic or
you're going to have
bigger problems than you ever had before
please respect
respectfully amount is more than trying
to reduce panic so we're in february
it's more deadly than your stress flu
go ahead please mr president don't you
think if you were more forthright with
the american people more lives could
have been saved
do you take responsibility at all for
some of the 200 000 deaths that we've
had
so i think if we didn't do what we did
we would have had millions of people die
we closed up our country we closed it up
very very quickly very effectively
we did a job we learned about this
horrible disease along with the rest of
the world which had to learn about it
and then we opened it up and now we know
the vulnerable we know who it attacks
who it's
so vicious against and i think we've
done from every standpoint
a incredible job we shouldn't have lost
anybody nobody should have lost
china released something that they
shouldn't have been allowed to
they should not have released it came
out of china
it went to europe it went all over the
world should have never happened they
could have stopped it
they stopped it from going into the
remainder of china it started in wuhan
and they stopped it but they didn't stop
it from coming to our country
now we had to show calm we had to show
you know if it was up to you or whoever
i have no idea what he said in the book
and again
it's a book that i gave him some quotes
and frankly we'll see how the book
turned out i have no idea you're
asking me questions for the first time
but again
the last thing we can show is panic
or excitement or fear or anything
else we had to take care of the we had
to take care of the situation we were
given now
long before anybody else wanted to do it
i closed our borders
to a very heavily infected china if i
didn't do that
we would have had hundreds of thousands
more people
die dr fauci said it many people said it
it was a great decision it was a
decision i made and i had to make it was
a decision that a lot of people thought
i was wrong
nancy pelosi said i was wrong joe biden
said i was wrong
they all came back and they said it was
the right decision and i was way early
that was in january the end of january i
did that
so that was a very good thing we did
otherwise we would have had hundreds of
thousands more but
if we didn't close the country we would
have been talking about millions of
people
instead of the numbers that we have
right now
you mentioned that you were trying to
avoid price gouging but you you
mentioned to bob woodward that you
recognize that this virus spread
through the air in on february 7th you
didn't begin project air bridge until
march you didn't use the defense
production act until march you didn't
start spraying
you didn't really think it was going to
be to the point where it was all of a
sudden the world was infected the entire
world was infected everyone was
scrambling around looking where to buy
face masks and
all of the other things we've opened up
factories we've had
tremendous success with face masks and
with shields
and with the ventilators we're now
supplying the rest of the world we have
all the ventilators we can use
and remember this the ventilators were
very important not one person that
needed a ventilator didn't get it
and these are very complex expensive
machines to make
we opened up something like hadn't been
done since the second world war
we honestly we've done an incredible job
but we don't want to
run around screaming shouting oh look at
this look at this we have to show
leadership and leadership is all about
confidence and confidence is confidence
in our country
and our people have been great we've
been put through a lot by
china by releasing this by having this
come here we were put to a lot they
could have done something about it
and they chose not to i am very honored
to have presented
to you today a list of 20 incredible
people
and we will talk later i'm sure we'll be
meeting later in the day
thank you from the threat in january
late january your new health
thank you